the super bowl of course is quickly  approaching and that means the hilarious  commercials are rolling in that's right  paul rudd and seth rogen take a trip  down memory lane in a new ad for lay's  potato chips bye everybody bye  i drink more water i drink more water  blaze brings back so many good memories  remember our road trip in 97.  [Music]  our first real heart to heart  i've never seen any of your movies not  even the ones together hey do you  remember when that stalker kidnapped us  yes laze was there  blaze  do you have a barbecue or a cheddar  jalapeno  oh remember when we stumbled into that  turf war  remember when you bought your first  house  those are good times  they were golden  you ready  seth do you i do and janet do you  that's yes  [Music]